au milieu des vastes plaines de
saskatchewan niché entre n'étant et des
pâturages un vieux bâtiment abandonné
attire le regard
[Musique]
une école parce que centenaire délabrées
poussiéreuses
l'une des pages les plus sombres de
l'histoire canadienne
celle des pensionnats pour autochtones
fb je n'ose y revient parfois et chaque
visite est pour lui l'occasion d'un
douloureux voyage dans le temps
c'est l'histoire d'une enfance volée
celle de gamme un autochtone arraché à
ses parents est placé de force dans une
institution chargée de le civiliser et
d'effacer sa culture de la simili
un drame parmi tant d'autres en un
siècle plus de cent cinquante mille
enfants ont ainsi été internés dans des
pensionnats pour autochtones
mis en place par le gouvernement fédéral
est géré par des communautés religieuses
des pensionnats synonyme d'abus et de
maltraitance
à masquer argen aide se souvient que les
coups pleuvaient en permanence pour
acquérir
et le soir venu le lit nos frais pour
cet enfant aucun réconfort aucune
protection
mais ça n'abîme
street
le pensionnat de masques à horgen était
entre les mains des oblats donc de
l'église catholique
mais les élèves de john gosden la
réserve voisine sous la férule de
l'église anglicane n'était pas mieux
traités
ben prat il a été interné à l'âge de 10
ans en hardcore belle
nombre historique
le directeur de l'école était un
pédophile notoire un prédateur sexuel
qui reconnaîtra plus tard avoir violé
des centaines d'enfants
et nous verrons
des viols systématiques commis pendant
des années en toute impunité sur des
enfants prisonniers
incapable de se défendre ou de dénoncer
comme ben aide a tenté de s'échapper à
plusieurs reprises mais chaque fois
évasion rim est avec munitions
comble de la torture psychologique de
son lieu de détention il pouvait voir la
maison de ses parents située à moins de
100 mètres
ed on a gardé de graves séquelles au
genou des blessures à l'âme aussi comme
presque tous les rescapés des
pensionnats des blessures beaucoup plus
difficiles à guérir
un argent de drogue
c'est dans la bible que brad a
finalement trouvé le réconfort et la
sérénité qu'il cherchait la force de
parler aussi pour tenter de briser un
cycle qui a mûri des générations
entières dans le silence et dans la
honte mais forcément mal d'elle à
chauray
ni
ici ni tous membres
[Musique]
oh
cynthia desjarlais est elle aussi une
ancienne pensionnaire lim perdu un frère
elle à faire reconnaître le pensionnat
que le site historique national et
l'espère maintenant faire un musée un
lieu de recueillement et de formation
d'ici là ces jouets et ses chaussures
ont été disposés à l'entrée pour
symboliser les victimes des douzaines
d'enfants disparus sans laisser de
traces
pour en avoir le coeur net le conseil de
bande a fait faire des fouilles à l'aide
de sonars pour localiser les corps
enterrés sur les terrains aux abords de
l'école
les drames vécus par ed béthune aux
ébène prat les ont rapprochés réunis par
une quête commune de justice et de
vérité
alors que l'on parle de plus en plus d'
excuse et de réconciliation au pays ces
survivants attendent plus que des
paroles destro un restaurant chinois à
s'approcher
[Musique]
la blessure est profonde et s'étend sur
plusieurs générations
sa guérison nécessitera donc bien
davantage qu'un simple acte de
contrition
gémir boc
[Musique]
en un mot réconciliation et pique aussi
réparation et donc nécessite de jeter
ensemble les bases d'une nouvelle
relation
mais